well Detroit Michigan is of course one
of the most violent places in the United
States when seconds count police will be
there in minutes that's why thousands of
law-abiding citizens in Detroit carry
their own firearms and defend themselves
so we went to Detroit to meet some of
the good guys who carry guns here's part
2 in our series on being legally armed
in Detroit Detroit emergency now this is
a nightmare situation for someone with
the concealed pistol license
I was arrested handcuffed and then taken
down to the jailhouse Marcus Weldon says
he was on his way home from an office
Christmas party dressed as Santa Claus
and he stopped at a gas station to help
a female co-worker change her tire
individual approached her during that
time I was changing her tire and
physically pushed her it was intoxicated
I intervened and it became a situation
where he wanted to retrieve his firearm
and we had the shootout
[Music]
was charged with seven felonies for
defendant myself as well as a friend his
church helped him cover more than
$50,000 in legal fees after more than a
year in court a jury cleared Weldon on
all charges
it was called the Sansa shooter after he
was arrested for opening fire dressed as
st. Nick
but now he wants to go buy a new name
freemen and has been acquitted of all
charges like thousands of Detroiters he
has a license to carry a concealed
weapon the police chief has actually
pushed from individual to carry there's
been research that shows criminals fear
armed citizens more than they fear
police why not just call the police well
the thing about it when you're dealing
with someone was intoxicated kind of
hard to de-escalate a situation and call
the police and hopefully the police
would arrive in time but a time will
call it's usually after the fact so
we're reacting to the crime Detroit's
police department faces a challenging
task than responsible for a city as
large as Philadelphia but with one-third
as many officers police departments are
staffed based on population police are
not everywhere every minute of every
block oftentimes out here that will
chief just hire more police officers I
mean it's not even realistic it's a
sentiment echoed by firearms instructor
Rick actor there's a high level of crime
here they will make every effort to get
to your residents as soon as possible
they may not get there fast enough this
is a not being a vigilante
I'm not advocating that but I'm also
advocating not becoming a victim and
this is about staying alive that's just
a reality that's anyway Detroit's rate
of justifiable homicides in which
criminals are killed by armed citizens
is 20 times higher than the national
average
bad guys love gun control additional
legislation anti gun laws would not stop
bad guys from plying their evil trade
bad guys have guns I think good guys
should have the opportunity have done
this world
Wheldon was reissued his carry permit
after he was exonerated and he still
carries to this day